Hello guys and welcome back to yeagerists!
In today's video, we will be going
through the story of Ymir Fritz.
Leave a like on this video and subscribe to our
channel if you want to see more content like this!
around 2,000 years ago, Ymir's village
was attacked and enslaved by the Eldians,
who also murdered her parents and
cut out the tongues of the survivors.
One night, Ymir opened the gate to a
pen, allowing for some pigs to escape.
Later, the tribe's ruler, Fritz,
questioned the slaves on the culprit.
The slaves pointed to Ymir, who was
released only to be hunted down for sport.
Wounded and desperate, Ymir found an
unusually large tree with a chasm at its base.
Seeking shelter, she stepped inside and,
not knowing of the sinkhole beneath,
fell down into a pool of liquid. There,
a mysterious spine-like creature fused with
her and turned her into the first Titan.
With her newfound power, Ymir returned to serve
Fritz and used her Titan to cultivate the land,
build bridges, and amass wealth for the Eldians.
Under his command, she also vanquished the armies
of Eldia's rival, Marley. To "reward" Ymir for
her service, Fritz took her as his concubine,
and together, they had three children:
Maria, Rose, and Sheena. It was speculated
that during this time, Ymir grew to
genuinely love and care for Fritz
despite his behavior and attitude towards her.
Thirteen years after acquiring the power of the
Titans, Ymir died while thwarting an assassination
attempt on Fritz, but then found herself in a
mysterious, barren land. King Fritz then forced
his daughters to eat their mother's corpse in
an attempt to preserve the power of the Titans. He
commanded his daughters to continuously reproduce,
to have their children eat their spines upon
their deaths, and perpetuate this ritual from
child to child so that Ymir's blood would not die
out and Eldia could rule forever with its Titans.
Ymir's power was divided into the Nine Titans;
and she continued to serve her descendants,
building them Titans whenever they
invoked the power of the Titans.
By the Eldians, Ymir's existence
is hailed as a god-given miracle.
The Restorationists claimed that she and all
Subjects of Ymir are "the chosen children of
God" and that any atrocities Marley claims Eldia
had committed could not have been possible because
Ymir would not have allowed it. There was even
an Eldian cult that worshiped Ymir as a goddess.
On the other hand, the Marleyans believe she
received her powers from a deal with the "Devil of
All Earth" and used this to ostracize the Eldians.
There are also those who believe that Ymir
contacted the "source of all living
matter" to gain her power. This theory
is relatively unheard of, as Grisha Yeager
was unaware of it until Eren Kruger told him.
Many centuries later, Frieda Reiss would visit her
half-sister Historia Reiss on the farm where she
was raised. During some of her visits, Frieda told
Historia the story of Ymir's deal with the Devil;
however, in the book she showed her, Ymir is
named "Krista". Frieda advised Historia that
she must be lady-like, as "Krista" was. She
spoke of "Krista" as being an altruistic girl
and urged Historia to be loving and beloved like
her when she is grown. However, Historia did not
remember these visits since Frieda used the
Founding Titan's power to erase her memories
after every visit. Historia would only recall
vague images of "Krista" in the years to come.
While on the verge of death from Levi's Thunder
Spear, Zeke Yeager would awaken in an unknown
land to discover Ymir resculpting
his damaged body with the earth.
During the assault on Shiganshina, Zeke and his
younger half-brother Eren Yeager are able to make
contact with each other and activate the Founder
before awakening in the Paths. As Ymir approaches,
Eren notices her presence. Zeke explains
that she is in fact the Founder herself.
He then asks Eren to go ahead with the Euthanasia
Plan. Eren refuses and demands that Ymir lend him
her strength, but his pleas are ignored. Zeke
subsequently reveals he has nullified the vow
to renounce war through Ymir, who obeys
only the royal family, her descendants.
She promptly restrains Eren with her chains.
After Zeke shows Eren the memories of their father
Grisha, Zeke realizes that Eren was responsible
for Grisha's actions against the Reiss family
and that his ultimate goal is inevitable. In a
panic, Zeke orders Ymir to sterilize the Subjects
of Ymir; and Ymir approaches the Coordinate
of converging paths to fulfill Zeke's will.
Eren manages to break free from his chains
and reach Ymir before Zeke. True to the Attack
Titan's yearning for freedom, he embraces
her and begs that she give him her power
so that he can "end this world." He assures
her that he is not going to force her hand,
recognizing that she is neither a slave nor
a god, but a human being with free will.
Eren presents her with two options: to wander the
Paths forever, or help him with his plans. As Zeke
desperately tries to stop them, Eren asks Ymir if
she was the one who called him to the Coordinate,
musing that she has been waiting 2000 years
for him to arrive. Ymir begins crying.
Back in Shiganshina, Eren's head reconnects
with his body. As everyone looks on in shock,
the Wall crumbles, releasing a horde of
Colossus Titans as Eren forms a new Titan body.
As Eren converses with his friends in the Paths,
Ymir emerges next to Eren in the Coordinate,
symbolizing their cooperation.
As the Warrior unit along with members of
Survey Corps engage numerous Titans on top of the
Founding Titan in an attempt to reach Eren at Fort
Salta, Ymir appears and is briefly seen by Armin
Arlert who speculates she is the one summoning
the previous incarnations of the Nine Titans.
After Mikasa Ackerman swoops into the mouth of
Eren's Titan, Ymir is shown to be standing
in the mouth, smiling as she watches Mikasa
kiss Eren farewell after killing him.
Immediately afterward, Ymir relinquishes
the Power of the Titans from the world.
Watching Mikasa kill the one she loves
was enough to release Ymir from the love she had
for Fritz who only wanted to exploit her power.
mir was the very first Titan and the only one to
ever possess the complete power of the Titans;
all who come after her merely possess fragments
of her power. Her Titan body was immense,
even by Titan standards, and easily towered above
the treeline. Using her immense strength, she
effortlessly wiped out Marley's forces. She was
also very skilled at controlling her Titan, as she
performed complex tasks such as building bridges
across mountains and cultivating the fields.
It is said that nobody can surpass Ymir and that
because Ymir died 13 years after awakening her
powers, no one is allowed to live beyond that;
this phenomenon is known as the "Curse of Ymir."
After Ymir's death, her spirit lived on
in a world where the Coordinate resides.
She is responsible for all Titan transformations
throughout history: Whenever the power of the
Titans is invoked, she builds the Titan
bodies out of the otherworldly sand.[9]
She is also responsible for regeneration and
re-sculpted Zeke's body after he was blown up.
It reportedly takes Ymir a very long time to
create these bodies: Zeke says it took her "years"
to build him a single human body, but because
the world in which she lives transcends time,
the process was almost an instant in
the physical world. According to Zeke,
Ymir can create anything, even chains that
represent the "vow of renouncing war."
Ymir is also the source of the Founding
Titan's power. From controlling other
Titans to creating the Wall Titans to
altering the bodies of the Subjects of Ymir,
all of the Founding Titan's feats are done by Ymir
after she is given the order, either by a scream
or in person through the world where Ymir resides.
However, because Ymir was Fritz's slave, she only
listens to the commands of the royal family; thus,
only the royal family can use the Founder's power.
Eren Yeager became the exception to this,
as he invoked the Founder on two occasions.
The first is when he punched Dina Fritz's
Pure Titan and commanded Ymir to make the
surrounding Titans attack Dina; and after she
was killed, he turned them against Reiner Braun.
The second is when Eren convinced
Ymir that she has a will of her own,
freeing her from the royal family's control,
and she lent her power to Eren instead of Zeke.
Thank you guys so much for watching
this video, it really means a lot to us.
We will see you guys very soon
in one of our next videos.